[Music]
hello and welcome to episode number 64
of the weekly Google cloud platform
podcast I am Franciscan boy and I'm here
with my colleague mark Mandel hey Mark
how are you doing I'm good France ask
how are you doing today very very happy
very excited about everything that is
going on right now it's pretty crazy we
are just getting into cloud next and
we're here at the cloud next community
summit yeah so we're recording this
today before so we're recording this
it's Tuesday tomorrow when these will be
released is day number one of top next
so we thought we would join the
community summit talk to some people
about what they be learning today and
what they're excited about for cloud
necks so yourself if you're going to be
a club next attending you can watch it
or later on what the recos on YouTube
yeah and just so you're aware this
episode will be a little bit short but
don't fret everything's okay what we're
gonna be doing is doing daily episodes
with interviews for the rest of our
lives no now for the restaurants oh my
god no okay we're gonna be doing daily
interviews on the floor with people at
next speakers people we find interesting
people I'm sure you'll love it so that
you can actually hear about next if
you're unable to attend or if you're at
next and you want some possible
real-time information about sessions
coming up you can also listen in as well
and if you are up next we are on the
ground floor we have a google cloud
platform podcast booth yep so and it
looks pretty cool so come say hi we have
t-shirts we have t-shirts and we have
stickers oh yeah cool stickers and we
have many colors to Rayna read well so
why don't we get started with the
interviews we have today we're gonna
start with a calif yeah callaloo Tarot a
good friend of the podcast because we
talked already about his project G dealt
with Felipe Hoffa so let's go talk to
him sounds good let's do that so we're
here today with Calif latero hi Calif
how are you doing it's great to be here
with you guys we're gonna be talking
today about the cloud summit but before
we do that wait on you
like in like two sentences who are you
what do you do so I run an open data
project called the GTL project which
looks at open data around the world
especially news media and uses a whole
range of google cloud technologies to
process this to really try to understand
what's happening around the world each
day and to really connect us more
together as a world so that you know
very few of us you know visited say you
know Burundi recently I'm to be able to
bring the world together see what's
happening in Burundi or in Syria or over
here in this corner of the world to
bring the world together so we really
see what's happening around us and can
build empathy and understand the world
around us oh I know you're you are a
very good friend of Felipe Hoffa from
our team so you use a lot of bigquery
but all the products three years oh and
I love bigquery I mean big queries is
amazing to be able you think about the
amounts of data that I that I generate
on the ability to look through billions
of records to be able to fold that data
so bigquery is a huge piece of this on
google compute engine obviously may
commence use of that on Google Cloud
storage it's amazing to be able to
generate a data file shove it out the
storage and it's just infant if a
million people start dialing that file
you don't worry about it most recently
actually start using the cloud ml tool
so clogged vision um so actually
processing global news imagery through
cloud vision to catalog what's the
visual narrative because today most of
what we do we do attacks usually when we
process the world but we forget the fact
that visuals so important so much of the
news is imagery i was using cloud image
or cloud vision um doing actually
applying cloud natural language so we're
starting to really explore what can we
use it that to really understand the
news and ways we've never been able to
before the number experiments are cloud
speech and found you know just
incredible be able to transcribe across
the world languages oh and so really
starting to leverage all these tools
that are out there um and you know and
that's what I love is it's really within
the Google environment a it's infinitely
scalable um but be the plug and play I
mean the fact that you know I could
literally make it API call and say you
know here's an image tell me what's in
this image give me everything you know
about that I don't have to worry about
learning tensorflow or learning all this
stuff but knowing that in the future
those the pathway is there so that if I
decide you know what I want to build a
custom model to do this I know that the
infrastructures data drop
deploy at the same scales awesome all
right well we're here at the community
summit for gcp next or for cloud next
what has been exciting what have you
been seeing today oh I've loved it i
mean the the meeting all these Google
folks especially it's a different
community of folks and I'm tip then I
typically interact with something great
seeing these other sides I mean hearing
especially you know things like you know
security and how Google have you know
has invested so much allow you to create
a secure cloud a scalable cloud I'm
seeing all these different sites have
been really exciting to me um to
actually hear you know from from google
itself um and and yeah I know it's it's
been fantastic here and you know I'm
looking you know to the rest of the week
it's so exciting to just I mean it's
really amazing as someone who has who
has lived in the supercomputing world
for a number of years um it's just
amazing being out here and see your the
scale is that you know Google operates
at it's really like like time traveling
to the future oh and especially being
from the Washington area you know it's
amazing oh coming out here spending you
a couple of days just basically it's
almost like you're sort of time
traveling you spend a couple days in the
future worse like you know here is you
know things that you've never been able
to dream of before and they're actually
reality available today um it's it's
just incredibly exciting that's amazing
so before we finish what are the single
thing or announcement that you know
about that you're looking at the mosque
forward to um you know there's no single
thing it and I think that's actually
what excites me so much about Google is
it's really easy to you know most
companies kind of fall into that that
you know that single thing where you say
oh yeah they do this um you know to me
I'm excited you know looking over the
next couple of days that the talks and
i'm most excited about range from you
know scalability and infrastructure of
your doing things that you know quarter
Google scale and the fact that that's
actually a term Google scale is amazing
um but I'm really am particularly
excited about you know sort of the big
data side like what are the things like
bigquery and that the things of being
able to deal with data on where you
don't have to you can history long story
short him you know things like bigquery
where historically people like me we had
to limit the questions we asked to the
to the to our abilities the tools that
we can bring together we're a big query
I don't even I don't even think about
you know is this question tractable
anymore I just do it
I just get the dancer you know to quote
han Solo are you from Star Wars or he
says I never ask that question till I've
done it um and you know I love that with
things like big cry so that's really
exciting to me and then the cloud you
know the cloud machine learning stuff to
see you know that the future of you know
bringing to bear some of the greatest
you know machine learning to or deep
learning tools that are out there and
you know where is google pushing that
needle because it's exciting to see how
fast it's evolving and that's evolving
as an API that people like me can can
access and do incredible things without
understanding any of that math behind
the scenes awesome okay thank you so
much for taking five minute to your time
out of your day to come here and I hope
you have a great cloud next experience
so thanks so much is it's great to be
here and I'm excited about the common
week thanks God for such an amazing
interview a bunch of very very good
sound bites that marketing really
appreciate such an exciting guy next we
have kind of a continuation of what
Calif was talking about he mentioned
that you know you can use many of our
products as simple API is like Club
vision but if you want to you can
actually dig deeper and basically go
down the tech stack and change things
down there and we're going to be talking
now to team Kelton from the card labs
they're showing us that we're showing is
a really cool that it's pretty pretty
amazing yeah and it involves can I using
like vision API but not vision API
instead what they did is they train a
new tensorflow model for the specific
use captions that they learn to do so I
think that that was a very interesting
topic so let's talk to him sounds great
let's do it we're now joined by Tim
Kelton from I always had out how to
pronounce it is the cathode discards
labs how are you doing Tim I'm doing
really good so it is the second time we
have you're here in the podcast but for
those people that have no heard have not
listened to the previous episode why
don't you tell us a little bit about who
are you what do you do sure i'm one of
the co-founders of decart labs and we're
a startup focused on machine learning
applied to aerial and satellite imagery
and then using that to see how their
earth changes every day awesome so I
know you're here for the community
summit but you actually just showed us
something super super
so our cool thing I'm gonna get silly
excited yeah can you tell us a little
about what it is and what it does yeah
so this is just launching right now it's
at a search at Descartes labs com and we
have many petabytes of satellite imagery
that we've pulled into Google Cloud and
then we basically run machine learning
algorithms over them to do a similarity
search so you can think of dividing the
earth up into really really small little
squares and then looking for something
interesting like a wind turbine and you
might say well where else and all of
this imagery are there wind turbines and
then what we'll do is we run that back
through our models and run all of the
satellite imagery through and it will
return back the top 500 most similar
images to what we just clicked on so I
think it is pretty interesting because
we were previously talking with Calif
and he was mentioning how he uses for
his project detailed he uses Club vision
and but you know Club vision is just
like a REST API and you can very easily
use it if you want to dig deeper you can
definitely change basically the engine
of how it works is that what you're
doing are you running Cloud email are
you running tensorflow tell us a little
bit about it yeah these are tensorflow
models and basically we extract a
feature vector for each of those little
tiny scenes that we see all over the
earth and that has a unique signature
and then we rank them we do a similarity
and which other features anywhere else
on the earth are similar so it's
something you could never scale you can
never hire a thousand people to just
rank every six single pixel all of our
world and say how similar is this to
this you know a you have to automate it
and have to use something like
tensorflow and I saw on the demo that
the demo the actual app that you can
scale in and out visually from like
America or China or basically sort of
other nations I believe you're using
Google Cloud storage for that is that
what's happening now yeah under the hood
we could never attach enough PD disks to
a single VM to store all of that imagery
so he had to have another solution so
we're actually storing all the the
compressed
tiled imagery in Google Cloud storage
and then we have a layer on top of that
called Festivus and that's a filesystem
layer on top of object storage and that
allows us system level access to just as
if it was native disk because and that's
really we can only do that because cloud
storage is just so fast returning back
the objects cool I'm actually curious
about two things first ace festivus I
don't know how to pronounce it correctly
but festivus is that open source by any
chance no it's just something we built
actually our CTO wrote all the code like
over a weekend pretty much in England it
got it all to run really well and it's
just been this really core part of our
infrastructure getting it to scale and
we're we're still a pretty small company
focused on you know building products
right now cool and the second one was
how are you actually managing this you
said there was petabytes of data and use
the mean and it just works like is there
some magic going on or just because
they're you know cloud storage is fast
well under the hood yeah we're storing
lots of we have a fairly sophisticated
processing pipeline to get all the
images in and have them all correct and
be really uniform and have a real nice
API in front of it but then in front of
that to serve it we have gke clusters
and managed instance group clusters that
we horizontally scale and then you have
front-end load balancers that are in
front of those instance groups and gke
clusters sounds like something we might
want to do a full episode on at some
point soon yeah why not yeah I think so
so um if people are attending next or
possibly looking out for recordings
later on I believe descarte labs has two
sessions at next this year sure if you
want to learn more about festivus and
how we're doing using Google Cloud
Storage at large scale there's a session
in its I 0242 that's on thursday at I
think 530 and then my session is talking
about postgres and how we use postgres
and that's on I think that's IO 235 on
thursday at 120 or 130 something like
that
we have links to the demos and your
sessions on the show notes and those
sessions will be recorded so if you're
not attending next don't worry because
you can watch them later on on YouTube
yep all right well thanks so much for
joining us here in our little area at
the community summit and thanks for
joining us and next thanks guys thank
you next up we are talking to Veronica
Lopez a a good friend of friends ask
especially because she writes a letter
go yeah she reads a lot of go and also
she's awesome so yeah we're going to be
talking to her about all the cool things
that she's excited for cloud next and
the cool things that she saw today the
community summit excellent let's go do
that I'm very happy to welcome Veronica
Lopez to the podcast how are you doing
Ronika I'm fine why don't you tell us up
for some like we it is weird but there's
people that do not know who you are why
are you consider Aviva who you are and
what you do um Veronica Lopez Veronica
Lopez Veronica llopis and I'm software
engineer I used to be a physicist and I
want to be episodes again at some point
but for now I'm a software engineer and
I used to ride mobile apps with Android
and now I ride go and I'm trying to
learn elixir nice yes so we are today at
the community summit for cloud next and
we just finished basically with most of
the meetings what it does a little bit
about it what was the best part for you
oh the best part for me was the
unconference part where we got to go to
different rooms and talk to experts
about different stuff in my case I chose
the machine learning room where people
even though they have lots of
experiences and backgrounds were I don't
know in taking baby steps and the
subject and everyone had a lot of
questions and I honestly thought that I
was the only ignorant person in the room
but it wasn't the case but it was a
positive thing because everyone started
talking
and asking genuine questions and I
didn't ask anything because they had my
very same question so it was interesting
and I don't know they were concerned
about how machine learning how not to
lie to people with machine learning how
it is very easy to do that and that
started like dancing in my mind and now
I'm very worried about and yeah that's
what's pretty interesting who was the
the expert managing the session do you
remember I don't remember his name but
ok that's fine here's good if you had to
get like one takeaway for anyone who's
listening he wasn't obviously able to
attend what would what would that one
takeaway be about that you got from that
session well in general the knowledge
that I got from it but how Google makes
it well tensorflow makes it super not
easy but approachable for people to get
into machine learning stuff and how well
another thing is that concerning while
regarding this issue of how not to lie
to people with machine learning and big
data stuff our conclusion was that you
have to use as many tools as possible
not use only tensorflow sorry and not
just math models and not just algorithms
but all of them together to get to UM
reliable conclusion cool so tomorrow is
the first actual day of Google club next
are you excited about any specific
session uh yeah yours thank you we do we
pay her for that isn't that is that how
that happens on I'm gonna buy her a beer
later what what are you excited about
France s session for uh I am excited
about learning how to use the google
tools i know that that sounds very
general and ICP paid me but but it's
it's genuine because I've had a chance
to work with Google cloud platform in
so many ways like for the continuous
integration stuff for the storage stuff
in many many things in tensorflow I was
trying to play with it but mm a lot of
times you have so many things to do with
it that you well at least in my case I
didn't know how to proceed and what to
do and most important of all like how to
really take advantage of this tool so I
am real looking forward to getting to
know from the experts how to really take
advantage of all of this resources yeah
we're gonna have the meet the experts
boots I think they're all around next
and also on top of that there's a bunch
of code labs that people can go and play
with so I hope that you won't show those
this is excellent well Veronica thank
you so much for joining us and I hope
you enjoy club next yay thank you Thanks
to everyone who joined us today inside a
little room our podcast booth here at
the community summit it was so nice that
you could join us really excited to be
doing daily episodes it's going to be
really cool doing this on the floor so
rather than seeing you all next week
we'll see you all tomorrow yep dr. you
all tomorrow
you